on l'a vu le ravisseur avait mis en
place un dispositif de dynamitage
particulièrement sophistiqué mais aussi
totalement machiavélique celles et ceux
qui ont pu le rencontrer le décrivent
comme quelqu'un de très froide
déterminée selon afp cet homme âgé de 42
ans s'appellerait eric schmidt il
portait sur lui des documents signés
human bomb ce qui explique les initiales
hb que signer les mémoires qu'il avait
remis à la police
renaud fessaguet l'homme qui angoissait
la france pendant deux jours s'appelait
eric schmidt
il avait 42 ans était d'origine pied
noir c'est lui qui a échafaudé seul sans
doute cette opération suicide face à son
ordinateur
il voulait être entendu des médias et
pourtant personne n'avait prêté
attention à sa première action publique
l'attentât le week-end dernier d'un
parking à neuilly signé de deux
initiales hb a précisé qu'il était bien
l'auteur de l'attentât commis le 8 mai
dernier dans le parking de nuit au cours
d'autres confient la notamment de
l'entretien qu'il a vécu avec le médecin
capitaine et sapeurs pompiers il avait
précisé que le cid hb utilisent étant
pour revendiquer l'attentât de nuit ou
pour signer les documents remis lors de
la prise d'otages signifiait human bomb
une bombe humaine voilà ce que voulais
tu es très riche qui est une idée fixe
une obsession même puisqu'en début de
semaine il avait annoncé à france soir
et la police
une action d'envergure ce fut jeudi
matin à neuilly dans la maternelle du
commandant charcot plus tard dans ces
protocoles de négociations avec la
police
schmidt réclamé la démission du ministre
de l'intérieur puis une rançon de 100
millions de francs laissant entendre que
c'était l'argent qui l'intéressé avant
tout en fait ceux qui l'ont approché ont
surtout noté sa détermination son calme
froid
sa paranoïa aussi une chose est sûre la
bombe humaine avait envie d'exploser
pour qui pour quoi à moins de confidence
faite aux négociateurs
eric schmidt pourrait bien avoir emporté
avec lui son secret